transport ministers are set to discuss
new rules on the maximum weights of
trucks buses and other heavy vehicles at
their council in luxembourg
the aims to improve aerodynamics fuel
efficiency and road safety
certain vehicles could have length
restrictions eased so that rear flaps
can be attached to cut down on wind drag
new cab designs will better deflect the
wind and increase safety and collisions
eu states would have six years after the
draft rules enter force to start
filtering out unfit vehicles
telecommunications ministers will take
stock of progress made on new rules to
ensure cyber security across europe
the plans to ensure a common high level
of electronic telecom security
and require all member states internet
enablers and critical infrastructure
operators to ensure a trustworthy
digital environment
discussion so far have highlighted the
need to strike a balance between
improved cyber security building the
necessary trust and making full use of
existing structures to avoid creating
new ones
the council will also focus on the
telecom single market the idea is to
create a single market for electronic
communications which will allow eu
citizens and businesses to use services
without cross-border restrictions or
heavy costs and for companies to operate
across borders regardless of where their
headquarters or clients are